my name is Guillaume I'm 29 years old
and I created an NGO called Scindia in
in France
starting now it's in six different
countries and basically what we do is we
connect refugees with member of all
societies around stuff that they love or
on things that they do what I'm
interested in is innovation is also a
sense of justice in our societies and
when I started work in Australia I was I
started to get be in touch with a lot of
refugees and asylum seekers and they
told me about all the dreams that they
had and I realized that nobody was
actually interested in that kind of
issues they were always talking about
admin about the legal aspects of seeking
asylum but nobody was talking about how
you unlock the potential of people you
know you read all the potential in a
society what are you trying to achieve
is to make sure that local people
actually really understand what they're
going through and what they could do
about it
and it's it's video bad crowdsourcing
because it's more important to actually
meet someone who works in the same field
than you than to go ten times to the Job
Center one of the biggest challenge is
the fact that it's a really cheap
political topic so when I started saying
it's about citizenship and it's about
innovation and it's about a lot of
different things people always go back
to you know a debate about whether
refugees are welcome or not and I think
it's not the question the question is
how you make sure that if you have
people on your territory you create
connections with locals but also you
make sure that they can I contribute
that society to testing existing for
citizen friends but we have people
telling us we want to start your
organization in Bordeaux energy in a lot
of different cities so we're changing
our job we've been for a long time
people who were organizing events people
where you know connecting ourself and
now we are going to be supporting local
people we do that
so the idea is to be present in a
thousand of cities in 2020 the fact that
every day I'm learning something the
fact that every day meeting with a chef
an engineer that's why I'm continuing
this it's amazing
[Music]